and now to this evenings discussion with
Edward Sayid and akhil McGraw me dr. Bob
Rami is the John Sounion professor of
philosophy here at Columbia and taught
at University of Michigan before coming
here where he has been teaching since
the mid 80s
dr. Moog Rami is the author of belief
and meaning and has two more books
coming out with Harvard University Press
next year
self-knowledge and resentment and
politics and the moral psychology of
identity which focuses in particular on
Islamic identity
dr. Saeed is University professor of
English and comparative literature here
at Columbia he is the author of more
than 20 books including Orientalism
covering Islam and culture and
imperialism his most recent publications
include the end of the peace process
Oslo and after reflections on Exile and
other essays power politics and culture
and parallels and paradoxes explorations
in music and society which is
co-authored with Daniel Barenboim
dr. Syed's Freud and the non European
will be published by verso in April of
2003 we're very very happy to see you
all here thank you very much for coming
and now Akhil big Rami and Edward Saeed
Thank You Jimmy it's really very nice to
have the chance to talk about Salman
Rushdie Edward is a good friend of his
it's been a friend of his for a long
time and has many common themes of
interests so it will be a very good
opportunity to smoke him out on some of
them I I don't know someone like Edward
does but it's hard for an Indian
especially an Indian with a Muslim
background not to admire him greatly and
really to think of him as sort of
elderly member of one's own family with
that kind of affection though he might
protest the elderly Edward I thought
we'd start with me asking you to to sort
of say something about the trajectory of
his writing I know you loved Midnight's
room and it first came out and and have
been reading it as avidly since then
especially as novels so so do you want
to to start by saying yeah well I will
be happy to
I met Salman Rushdie at somebody's house
in the early 80s and I must have it
about 1982 I hadn't at the time read
Midnight's Children which came out two
years before but I had it which is a
important first step obviously and I
recall our exchange was was about that
he had read Orientalism but I hadn't
read Midnight's Children I said that I
would do so
after we went home Tom and I did and I
was mightily impressed with it because
it struck me as the novel of a of a man
with the gifts of genius
first of all linguistic gifts of a
terrifyingly fertile and almost Joycean
sword turning you know the most humdrum
things into fireworks verbal and
intellectual fireworks he was also you
know a man who understood and was
interested in dealing with the history
of his own country from a perspective
that I thought at the time was really
quite unique I really haven't met
anybody or read anybody quite like him
that is to say he was a he was an Indian
who was very English at the same time I
remember when we met he talked about his
having been a student at was it rugby I
mean English public sorry yeah and then
he studied oriental studies at Cambridge
aslam was his field then and he had been
in in London for several years during
the time that he was writing Midnight's
Children which I said appeared in 1980
but he had worked as an actor he had
been a writer of advertising copy which
which you've actually seen in some of
the passages in Midnight's Children and
some of the later novels are he's great
at what you know might be called squibs
or you know jingles which turn up
obviously in this tannic verses
in other places and was was in it in his
accent and manner not the way he looked
obviously but in Saxon man it was
extremely English at the same time that
he was also a mistakenly Indian so it
was a melange that fascinated me and I'd
never really encountered it and I
thought that Midnight's Children is a
great sort of anti epic epic of the
birth of modern India after the part
after the independence 1940 August 1947
with which the hero of the novel is
associated he's born on the night when
the British seed India to the Indians
was a work of the most extraordinary
power and wit and insight particularly
in something we may come back to in that
the book is impregnated with British
imperialism I mean even though it's the
end of imperialism the Empire still
lives on in in so many ways in
characters and rituals and memories and
buildings and occasions and of course
above all in this language which like
Joyce and outsider Rushdie makes his own
thereafter I saw quite a bit of him both
in England and in America he would keep
he's always had a very great interest in
popular culture and particularly
American popular culture you know and
but his subsequent books you know shame
which deals with the india-pakistan or
of the middle 60s Satanic Verses later
the Satanic Verses yeah but he also
published in the middle 80s a book that
was I think very very interesting a
collection of essays which came out just
before the fatwa which was eight 1989 so
this one must have come out 87 88 called
imaginary homelands which gives a very
interesting idea of his essay istic
scope I mean he was very very prolific
in writing reviews and appreciations and
polemics
particularly about something we'll come
back to
about British racism multicultural
Britain and racism in it and what he
called I mean a phenomenon that he
identified as Roth revivalism and the
return to you know in the jewel in the
crown in the making of the film Gandhi
and things of that sort where you look
back at Empire with a certain kind of
sentiment sentimental nostalgia he was
merciless in dealing with that but he
also dealt rather prophetically with the
role of writers and politics and his
biggest essay in the book is called
outside the whale which is a kind of
rejoinder to Orwell's essay which begins
with Henry Miller called inside the
whale and the argument is there that
there is no outside to the whale the
whale being society that you know we're
all we're all involved and there's no
such thing as a non-political uninvolved
writer but if you read those words now I
mean they have a kind of eerie you know
quality to them because in a couple of
years he was going to be immersed in
this terrible direct quandary right and
then of course the Satanic Verses
appeared and I recall very well that in
the no but my and my wife and I spent
July the 4th I think it was in 1987 with
Salman and his then second wife an
American novelist called Mary Ann
Wiggins they are just bored and it was
July the 4th yes the weekend and they
had just bought this new house in
Islington and you know and someone was
very excited about July the 4th and we
had fireworks in the garden I mean can
you believe it was but I remember I
remember I remember with great clarity a
moment that took place early on in our
visit where he took us on a tour of the
house and we went to his study and there
on his desk was this gigantic manuscript
you know like that it was in those days
it wasn't quite the period of computers
I'm gonna keep is all tight and he said
this is my new novel and I said oh
really what's it
he said it's about Islam I said oh
really he said but I said in a way you
know your other novels have been about
this lab - he said oh now Edward don't
get me wrong the direct quote the
Muslims are gonna be very angry
I said really why he said because I
talked about Gabriel I talked about the
Prophet Mohammed and so on and so forth
he said it's a comic novel I said oh
well that sounds fascinating could I
read it he said of course but it was so
big I couldn't carry it so he said I'll
send it to you and indeed about a week
later or two weeks later when I came
back to America the book arrived at my
doorstep and I and I had in fact that
very valuable saying a manuscript copy
of The Satanic Verses
and then we moved that very year and
from one house to another and away I
mean having read you gave me a copy of
it I actually have it so
so you just discarded it I mean I take
it I tell him yeah but but you know I
remember an occasion in your flat when
you were here in Morningside Drive
Vedek bar yes and your mother was
visiting from DC and and he was telling
us Salman was there as Karen was there
and he was telling us about what was in
The Satanic Verses
and I think you had received it but you
hadn't read it and it was said you know
they're gonna kill you and but he knew
that he would make a lot of people angry
but I don't think he realized this is a
polymer it was a very dear friend of
mine who died about three years ago four
years ago actually and who news I mean
who met so man
through me yeah so I mean I don't think
anybody expected I don't know whether
you read it shortly thereafter and I
mean I I looked through it I must
confess not to have read every single
word of it at that time I did later and
I was you know aware you know of what
sort of dynamite was in the book yeah
but not I had no idea of what was going
to happen to hold on but just get him
back to Midnight's Children you know it
had a tremendous impact on Indian riders
I mean this suddenly or you know all
sorts of people began to write novels in
that vein and with politics being very
central to the writing into the themes
in fact a friend of mine Michael K
Sherman was a novelist - in a scholar of
Islamic history presented richly with
his first novel saying an inscription
saying thanks for the four-minute mile
yeah because really it was it was it was
as if he broke a barrier and then
everybody started just sort of you know
doing much the same thing and and the
different things sort of rifts on it and
so on and did it have an impact on on
writers in the Middle East very much so
yeah I mean I think I think it brought
home too many of them the the the sort
of combination of magic realism and
nationalism that was quite unique to the
novel and that and that you know some of
the writers well I mean the Lebanese
novelist silly-ass Hui who - my
introduced seven or the other way around
to the South map has always found him a
very interesting novelist for that
reason that is a it's a it's a it's a
new way of dealing with with nationalism
in a way you know it's kind of
irreverent right and yet mythic at the
same time with with tremendous sort of
Verve and and and above all something
like we must insist on with a tremendous
comic sense yes I mean you know the the
I mean for example that great scene
where the doctor examines the mother of
the hero through that hole in the in the
sheet and and all the business about
hiding under the under the doorstep
either under the floor you know which
was actually a recollection of fast I've
met fast as he told me later what you
know is what had a great and tonic
effect on young especially young right
and especially those who were likes a
man who are expatriates
you couldn't say that he was at that
time I said he write an exile he chose
sort of an insurer not sure and he had
one other point which I didn't I've
found out early on but I never read it
he wrote a novel before when that
children she's called Primus which is
English but but but yeah I think I think
the the the appearance of Midnight's
Children produced of a whole library of
Anglo Indian books and a whole you know
like ministry and they have not liked
him right well try to imitate him but he
certainly opened the way for really a
new mode of writing and and also the
last point certainly a new not a new but
I mean a kind of jealousy I mean he
became the person whom everybody either
tried to emulate or kill or I mean I
don't mean you know actually kill
although that the last happened but but
you know he became the figure that you
had to measure yourself against for
young writers and resentments you know
from writers who were not as well known
as the a who had been around for a while
etcetera right so a governing theme of
Midnight's Children is is the sort of
legacy of colonial rule in India and so
that's a lifelong theme theme of yours
do you do you think that that really
gets a lot right in Midnight's Children
that I mean apart from the brilliance of
the writing and so on other is there a
sort of perceptiveness about
post-colonial I mean not India
necessarily but but the sort of ethos
that comes from myself I mean I you know
sort of embarrassed to talk about India
India's past as reflected at the
colonial past as reflected in something
like Midnight's Children in the presence
of yourself and Nick Dirk's and others
who know much more about it than I do
but it but I thought was really quite
unique and and and ingenious about
Rusty's work what was the sense that he
gave you of it of the two histories that
of pre and post colonial India is really
in two overlapping I mean that they
couldn't be thought of as just two
separate things yeah but that one
continues in the other and and then the
other the newer history of you know post
47 India constantly is involved with and
looks back to the past and that invents
its own past I mean so that sort of
modern India idaite invents an identity
for itself that is based on on British
India I don't think he's particularly
kind to imperialism I mean certainly not
in his essays and other things that he
writes at the same time but but there is
a sense in which imperialism is part of
Indian history and can't be thought of
as you know as a thing that ended in I
mean that I think it's a point of the
novel in a way that all those things
began anew on August whatever it is 1947
you can't say that everything just
stopped and Roman world began and I
think that's the major theme really of
the of the kind of post-colonial world
as I see it and I think Midnight's
Children reflects as well yeah you know
I always find my nature to be a book
actually which is very very saddening
and pessimistic anywhere just and really
sort of one is distracted from that from
that kind of response only by the
brilliance of its writing and what you
discovers the comic the sort of
unstoppable comic element from beginning
to end and the reason for that and this
is something that I wanted to ask you
really because it's so much the
trajectory of
colonized peoples and of people like
yours who are still colonized but who
one expects and hopes will cease to be
soon that they begin their lives at
midnight in on independence with such
great hopes and they have futures in
their minds really as you know the
protagonists of Midnight's Children the
children and those futures which are in
their minds never become I mean they
become pasts before they were ever in
the present you know they it's the by
the end of the novel and and so I think
it seems very much the the experience of
people of the X colonies that that
independence came with with such hopes
and nothing seems to have been redeemed
in in history yeah I I think it's I
think it's a the case with his
generation he's a younger one than mine
I mean they're references in the novel
as I recall not having you read it in
yours but I mean there are references to
modern post-independence history for
example the Bannerman period the Suez
Crisis of 1956 is referred to but that's
all you know in a sense part of history
and you know the disappointments and the
and the absence of the kind of
enthusiasm that was associated with the
early period with Nehru and talk is over
I mean this is the period of of Indira
Gandhi and and I think it's a different
post-colonial period one with with
without much sentimentality for the past
right it's not heroic you know some
lines novels on the whole of generally
tend to be anti-heroic and there there
is a certain tall it bitterness but
there's a critical edge to it
about well certainly you see it in shape
I mean about the contemporary
institutions the military the the kind
of the kind of posturing of nationalist
leaders who have in a sense stayed on
too long yeah I mean it's I wouldn't
call it quite pessimistic the way you do
but I think the flush of enthusiasm I
mean that's what the novel is about it's
about growing older and shedding
illusions about you know the great new
dawn of independence that you know the
character is born into on the first page
because there's also that famous you
know exchange of babies that takes place
so that from its very start history is
displaced and and must be in a certain
sense a kind of mock history rather than
a networked history in that sense I
think it's very clever you done yeah and
but by the time he comes to shame but
the time you die shame that I mean
there's hardly an appealing character in
the whole novel it's the N system and
and really it's about the the tremendous
corruption among power elite especially
the leaders and you must have in in the
context of being colonized and you know
when I've read your criticisms of some
Palestinian leaders and so on it seems
so very deep-seated in in and Seamus is
a corrosive sort of look at at that and
that must ring very true for you yeah no
I mean I yeah I mean these are i mean
shame in particular is it all really
about sort of stay I mean it you'll get
you'll cast our efforts it's about
staying on too long I mean people who
have stayed in power too long and who
have corrupted the contempt contemporary
society were there we're there how much
I call it with their obsessions and with
their petty concerns and and above all
was met with militarism I mean there's a
lot of that also my own history I mean
you know the
and the history of modern Pakistan I
mean you know the numbers of coos you
know the emergence of a kind of core
sort of cabal almost which I he's very
good about them you know within
governments but but I think the
difference between between Midnight's
Children and shame is that I think shame
is a much more sober novel for me yes
sure therefore less less interesting
less enjoyable I mean it doesn't have
the reach and the you know tremendous
energies of Maronites children which is
also I mean I suppose it's apt for this
soon to take place opening of the see
I'm it's very theatrical in many ways
you know and reflects his own experience
in the theatre and has a lot of mimicry
in it and so on and it's very much oh
but what important point if I might just
one of the interesting themes in his
career during the 80s that has said
before the before the fatwa was a kind
of I wouldn't call it rivalry but there
was a quiet attempt to distance himself
from the other major Indian writer
writing in English name you VS Naipaul
I mean there's a sense you know in which
is a great competition between rich T is
much younger than night but my poll was
the man who you know I represented not
only not you know not only the business
about you know writing about the third
world which of course Rushdie does too
but but but also about the
disillusionment which is one of seven
themes as well but nightfall was there
was disillusionment and a kind of
bitterness and I kind of you know
especially these books about travels in
the Islamic world like among the
believers which which someone wrote a
review of and it appears in imaginary
homelands that is to say he doesn't he
doesn't take the same tone there's still
a great deal of affection and compassion
in in rust-eze view that isn't to be
found in eyebrows and I think what's
also interesting I mean this is really I
shouldn't say this but I remember once
or twice actually once here on the
corner of 116th and Broadway saying that
you know it was
kind of strange that night Paul's
writings you know not call having
written much more nonfiction than he
wrote fiction lots of essays on books
and obviously travel and so he never
once mentions not rusty at all you know
paid no attention to deliberately I mean
you can't not pay attention to Rusty
during it during the 80s but night Paul
did and the bitterness I mean he did not
pay attention and the build earnest and
the kind of thing and the kind of attack
on the myths about colonialism by the
formerly colonized hmm was a subject
that that Rushdie dealt with it an
entirely different much more as I say
compassionate and much more humane way
than Naipaul it was always eager to
deflate the the past and say not that
colonialism lasted too long it didn't
last long enough I mean look what
happened after the white man left was
his name you know they all and and
particularly in I Paul's work the kind
of bitterness in in the
post-independence world what you don't I
don't think although he treats it in
shame I mean if you look at a novel like
a bend in the river of night Paul you
know that kind of you know how Conrad's
Africa after Lumumba and and and in the
independence periods they characterized
by Sean Bay and some of the others is
really worse than under King Leopold you
don't get you don't get that sense in
Rushdie where the past has looked at you
know with criticism you know the
imperial past looked at with criticism
but not with a kind of you know
acceptance and you know which they had
stayed a bit longer and we should have
him back etc he makes fun about the
monthly right and part of that I think
is because in novels case there's a very
sort of deliberate and cultivated
ignorance right I mean I don't about
things like real history I mean real
historical knowledge of all ages he's
writing about political economies of the
places writing about
I mean it's a very deliberate attempt to
say I'm going to observe the surface
culture and give an incisive
which he does
sort of set of observations and critique
of it but it's somebody like Bruce Lee
actually for instance in the Satanic
Verses he really studied Islamic history
and and its early period of Islam that's
why it goes for the jugular really
because it understands it very well and
and has a sympathy for the possible
progressive turn the monetary in Islam
and so on and and the sympathies he has
for a socialist India at India where
where the nationalism is subdued by a
kind of multicultural set of sympathies
and so on those are things that emerge
because he sort of understands the
recent history he knows his bonding as
you say he knows the leaders and what
they stood for where they came from what
and all that is whether he knows it or
not it seems almost as if he's
deliberately shut it out in the case of
991 you know in order to well not only
set it out but I mean he really writes
out of a deep antipathy to Islam I mean
the second book I can't remember the
name of it among the believers was the
first one where he goes to Malaysia
Pakistan Iran and I think Pakistan and
writes these sort of devastating
portraits of society official portraits
of Iran after the Islamic Revolution and
so on and then he then ten years later
he writes the same book he goes back to
the same guy kept under the name with
that book but there's a kind of visceral
dislike of Islam yes which you don't get
in in Rusty's book because he writes
from the interior I mean for him you
know Islam and Hinduism and you know the
religions of India you know a flurry
religious
direct society are very much what he
wants was in the case of Naipaul he
regrets yes the mongrelization wrote of
the world which is which is Sal man's
world and subjective fact that the world
is made up of these hyphenated people
you know and and he celebrates them and
there's a great energy in the writing he
does and he's very interested also I
mean one has to also say that one of the
books he wrote in the 80s
also before this time
was a book called the Jaguar smile which
I reviewed actually which is a book
about his voyage to Nicaragua it's
important to remember all these things
because Salmons political views have
changed over time no but I mean he was a
he went he went and he was a visitor to
the to the to the Sandinistas you know
he was taken around and wrote very
sympathetically about them and about
Nicaragua as it was being attacked and
subverted by the United States you know
and and it was a quite I mean it was a
quite courageous bullying to do and you
know it didn't it didn't get a
tremendous number of sales but I think
it made him you know an important
contribution to the struggle against
Empire I mean the new Empire of which he
was very much a you know an opponent in
those days right you know I was thinking
when you talked about Islam in that sort
of mongrel sense it's interesting that
for an Indian Muslim no it's LOM came to
India via pressure and Turkey and
Central Asia and sort of kept acquiring
some local accretions in that journey
and so it became a very much more local
phenomenon you know syncretic continues
with with the Hindu culture and life and
yet there was also a sort of double
movement because there was this sort of
differential gaze to Arab lands and and
the sort of normative in and scriptural
elements you know the transcendental
elements of the religion you know was
another side of it and and there's the
sort of interesting double movement and
in Indian Islam and really his the links
between Midnight's Children and Satanic
Verses is to actually play those two
against each other oh absolutely I mean
not only that but I mean they're out
right they're out right how should I say
for castings you know things in the
Satanic Verses
in Midnight's Children for example the
father of the hero
I mean Sinai your father wants to be
left alone in his later years why
because he wants to rewrite rearrange
the Quran but she says it's very badly
sort of math yeah put together book and
his idea is to retire quietly to
rearrange the the book in such a way as
to give it a new kind of order well
that's a scene you know that comes back
at me and the whole idea also of
inventing traditions is very much the
way he he treats Islam I think in in
Midnight's Children as something that
people constantly talk about and revise
because precisely it's not I mean this
is something that night Paul attacked
was where's misty you know has a great
affection for it is it it's not in a
sense our native religion therefore we
can we have to give it a native face a
native version here in India and it's
much more playful I mean so there's even
in those in those early books there's a
sense in which Islam is not too severe
ascetic you know kind of unpleasant
it's a puritanical fundamentalist thing
but rather you know it it blends quite
well with some of the you know some of
the aspects of Hinduism for example the
Muslims would ordinarily not be
congenial right feel congealing you know
about but in this case are really quite
attractive and Islam is seen through
that prism rather than through that of
7th century Mecca
she parodies of course in the Islamic in
the Islamic you know yeah and yet now
when when he writes about Islam that
this does the constant I mean you know
now talking about just eat mark to
the this is constant since you have with
with him that it's it's become a
fundamentalist religion in many parts of
the world and and it's foolish in a way
well it is all right you know and that
it's foolish in a way to to say things
like well people turn to it because of
genuine grievances and so on
he's much cleaner to say its name really
is tyranny this is just fooling
ourselves we must fight it even if with
the war if necessary right I you know a
little time to go over I mean I I agree
with what you're saying in general but
because you know I have followed his
career quite closely and at times you
know soil quite a bit of him and was
involved in a very very peripheral way
in the struggle about the Satanic Verses
it's actually it's it's a very painful
story his relationship with Osama
because we mustn't forget for example
that in the early 90s it must have been
in a year or two after the fatwa he
wrote an essay which were appeared in
the New York Times and which is the
concluding essay in this wonderful
collection of his that I referred to
called imaginary homelands it's entitled
why I have become a Muslim and where he
converted a Baptist ma'am I think to be
honest with you that I don't know
anybody who wouldn't have had a
tremendous sense of disorientation
showed he was under new orders yeah I
mean after the onslaught against his
book when it appeared in 89 sure and he
went through a tremendous number of
phases obviously of confusion of
resistance of wanting to be you know
welcome back in to be accepted then of
denial and anger I never forget the year
he came here when I invited and he came
twice I think but the last time you came
which was about four or five years ago I
think you
we had a conversation at the Miller
Theatre the first question I asked him
was of course after he was able now to
travel and whatnot
99 I think it was and I said to him it's
like sir man do you how do you feel
about being a member of the Islamic
Ummah you know the community and he said
I don't feel I'm a member of it at all
it's something you know I hate it it's
you know and for him Islam was Iran at
that point right but if you look back to
his other writing I mean earlier writing
than that particular moment it was a
much more modulated view that was the
sense in which his system was was a
complex and interesting religion which
had many parts to it you know Indian and
Persian and whatnot that there was a
British Islam but then the whole thing
fell on his head with the with with the
fatwa and you know I I we communicated
in those first few months and even years
what he was in hiding most of the time I
mean you couldn't reach him except
through let's say a third that sometimes
a fourth person and I recall as a matter
of fact it I think it was in 1990 anyway
she's not here
oh there you are was at 1990 that we saw
him yes in London he was in Heidi at the
time and he was surrounded by these
policemen and Scotland Yard and you have
to make the arrangements the day before
and they come and they sticks we were
staying in the houses the house of a
friend who wasn't there so they given us
a house and so the the the Scotland Yard
people come to day before and then they
come an hour before the appointed time
and then one of them comes in and then
he comes in and in disguise or wearing
some thing and the policemen were always
in the house I mean they were on the
second floor in this case and you know
there was he he looked terribly
unhealthy he was always indoors you know
he got fat his skin was pasty and yellow
he looked awful and he was a man who was
suffering and as I think I'm just not
trying to flesh out what it must have
been like the sense that you know that
his own people and religion had turned
against him because
here they were the English Pakistanis
and English Muslims were the most
vehement in a way you know Bradford
where they burnt his book and he was the
subject of sermons and then all through
the world
yeah the Islamic world agrees you know
so that I think it's a very what I'm
trying to say almost impossible to
handle I don't think anybody could have
done it right yeah any better really
yeah and the lesson is that persecution
doesn't make people say sensible things
very often yeah but but they don't you
know here's my thought and and I'd
really like to know how let's explore
this for a moment
you see it's absolutely right there's no
gainsaying that the fact that there are
fundamentalist elements in Islam all
over Iran us here and in the Middle East
in South Asia and so on and Bradford but
I think it's sort of ubiquitously true
nevertheless that most people most
Muslims are not like that
no I agree with so now so here's a
thought a question if most people are
not like that it's still nevertheless
true that for reasons that you've
written about at lengthen and depth they
nevertheless find it very hard to openly
and strongly criticize the
fundamentalists in their midst even
though they are not fundamentalist they
propose the fundamentalist they can't
easily come out and say sir not
necessarily out of fear of the
fundamentalist because to do so would be
in their own perception of things to
capitulate to a whole colonial history
of saturation of continuing subjugation
in Muslim lands not in the guise of
standard forms of colonialism but new
forms of
and to come out and openly be critical
is innocence a bind for them because it
would be as if one is just sort of
capitulating to that history and to its
present manifestation right right so so
one of the pressing questions for
somebody who's so deeply interested in
Islam is as rich the is is how should we
give these people who are not
fundamentalist who are basically either
indifferent fundamentalism or opposed to
it the confidence right to say this is
not Islam we don't have to do this and
and so on how should they have the
confidence to be able to do that well I
think it certainly won't they won't get
the confidence if one takes the kinds of
stances that Salman is now start to take
yeah I think and oh I see your point I
see your point
I think because he's been so embattled
and because in a way he was trying to
well to save his own life who can blame
him for that he he wasn't perhaps as
aware as he could have been of the many
people in the Muslim world who defended
him and in fact really spoke out I'll
give you an example and it must have
been in the early 90s he was still you
know underground a Moroccan woman in
Paris but there were two women decided
that they would put together a book
which was called in French poor rusty
for in which they would get a hundred
testimonials to Rusty from the Islamic
world from prominent practice you know
from Turkey from West Africa from India
from the Arab world all over the Arab
world you know and put it together as a
book to show that the Islamic world was
not made up essentially a fundamentalist
search if raving fanatics and and the
book appeared I contributed to it and
the book appeared and it was then
published in English by George Brazil er
you know I think it may have sold five
copies no I mean I think it's very
significant that this is a book that
really was you know frayed it with an
enormous amount of significance for the
people who took this position which is a
very unpopular as you say position here
and and in the sense made Rushdie's
cause their cause as a way of fighting
battles in their own countries in their
own societies first of all it
immediately established the fact that
Islam is not monolithic you know there
isn't just one vast bodies of people you
know wearing turbans and waving
scimitars and saying kill the infidel
that kind of thing and that there were
different different Islam and there were
different situations in each of the
cultures were silent each of the
countries of Islam and that there were
many people of whom this was a symbolic
hundred who were willing to stand up for
freedom of expression and and the
freedom of the writer and you know using
aesthetics as a as a means of expression
against fanaticism and dogmatism in
authority well I mean that but I mean
that hasn't been recognized you know I'm
not sure that he recognized it I mean
why should he but I mean I'm just saying
you know there are things like that and
that and that and and and though there
has always been you know unlike the
diatribes of people like Huntington who
have tended to talk about the clash of
civilizations or the clash of cultures
there have been lots of people who have
crossed from one realm or the other you
know including our friend a trial
himself you know was a Muslim and myself
I'm not a Muslim I mean I grew up in a
Muslim children world surroundings but
but I consider it my culture even though
I happen to been born in a Christian but
in an Islamic culture where the language
the lingua franca is Arabic and so one
can live in a world like that and of
course one also has to make the point
which he tried to I think in the mores
last saw hmm in the Andalusia novel that
come
after the Satanic Verses that the
culture of islam particularly if you
look at it in spain and you know 13th to
14th century was a plura cultural one
yeah that islam was much more tolerant
than europe I happen to be reading now a
book by the Israeli writer I'm a see
Lorna mm-hmm about the fate of the Jews
in Germany I can't remember the title it
just came out a few months ago and I
know a Lord he's a Issa Disraeli who's
very very critical of the Israeli
government and is very depressed about
the current situation in any case in the
early part of the book he talks about
the strictures against Jews in Europe
hmm you know until the French Revolution
basically and there is simply nothing
like that in the history of Islamic of
the Islamic world where Jews of course
constituted a fairly important minority
in places like Iraq and Yemen and stuff
where Jews were not allowed into this
we're not allowed to wear shoes in
cities like Frankfurt for example we're
not allowed into the main part of the
city without a Christian who will come I
mean the most barbaric persecution and
invidious sort of discrimination against
them you know by the exactly the great
enlightenment countries of Europe
Germany and France and so on and so
forth well I mean some I think some
awareness of that is very important I
think when you contrast with Indonesia
in contrast with the millet system under
the article which is but I think what
what what has now happened in in the
world after 9/11 is that there there has
been you know a kind of polarizing
struggle between the whole Islamic world
misrepresented my you know a salad bin
ladin etc etc and you know the world has
represented by George Bush and I think
that I mean both her equally or in my in
my opinion are equally false you know
and therefore can't be taken as symbols
of
yeah but now I want to talk about you
and everybody minute because that way to
agree that we're gonna do now I you know
in these last words you you've been
distancing yourself from some of his
positions on recent political
developments and I just want to ask you
since since you don't take that view
and I don't and many people here I'm
sure don't
does anybody know anybody here who is
for the war at this moment I don't know
I haven't met a single person who is but
anyway that's another subject go ahead
guys so good so will you please preach
to the converted over the next two well
how should we sort of live and think
with hope now if we don't well III think
the main hope derives the fact that
there are a lot of people who are
prepared to speak out against you know
against massive Wars at the same time
that they are very critical of you know
terrorism in the name or violence in the
name of religion but who understand I
think at the same time that you know
that we have to live I think the way the
Europeans have come to terms with it
partly because there are so many Muslims
in Europe today I mean they're you know
the second largest religion in France
today is Muslim so and in Germany has a
huge number of Muslims you know Turks
and Kurds and Arabs and so on who live
there that that that Islam has become
not some outside force as it has has
become for Americans understandably
because of 9/11 horrible the site of
these planes crashing into the World
Trade Center and causing such havoc and
such senseless suffering but even in
Europe like the the formal apparatus of
democracy it's completely divorced no
that's what I was coming from another
way in other words there's a sense here
in some parts of Europe leaving us out
England for a moment and in parts of
Europe where
where you know whether there's a there's
a sense that the future has to be based
upon a sense you might say of
international community what kind of
glory of an integrated world in some way
which fosters coexistence and in
exchange between cultures that may not
like or or accept each other but who
have to live in a small planet and in a
sustainable and humane way I don't think
that's the case here
alas I mean in this coordinate or
England or know what I mean those
governments I mean no I mean England is
it's quite dramatic it's a little
there's a major failure of democracy in
in some of the Western democracies
including ours I mean right the I don't
care what the polls say and how the
questions are asked but I there is a
major feeling of unrest in this country
about the mobilisation of war which has
nothing to do with in the end being for
Saddam Husein
nobody's forces are and etc the same in
England when when 85% of the population
is against the war in Italy you know
something like 90 percent in Spain 94
percent are against the government's
position but what I'm talking about is
how a relatively small cabal of people
for their own purposes I mean have
really have really mounted the
barricades and are leading a ruinous
crusade to destroy and redo the world in
in the Middle East for reasons that have
nothing to do with democracy that have
to do with the preservation of of access
to cheap oil the preservation of Israel
and very much at the corpus which isn't
mentioned today at all in the media and
talking about the Middle East people
like pearl and Wolfowitz and Douglas
Feith and all these other people where
advisors to Netanyahu in his prime
ministerial campaign in 1996 in which
they advocated the annexation of the
West Bank the end of the peace process
to stop Oslo whatever it was doing and
to attack Iraq and now this has become
the official for seven years ladies
become the official policy of the US
government it doesn't represent the
policy of the vast majority of people in
this country who are ill informed by the
media and so on and
have a sense in which the world of Islam
as I don't know who calls it that
somebody is this this ridiculously
demonized thing nuclear weapons right
yeah
and and you know we have to fight
against it with more now unfortunately
in this battle in the last few months
Salman has to me inexplicably turned up
on the side advocating war I mean I I'll
never forget it hunk ago I don't want to
make it sound as if it was you know
forty years ago it was about two months
ago mmm I I picked up a copy of the
Guardian I was in England or yeah it was
a thinking exactly it was about the 24th
the 25th of January and there was an
article in The Guardian and saying who
are the British Hawks and there was of
course Tony Blair I mean at the top of
the list pictures of each of these
people and Michael Howard and Willie
Shawcross and Christopher Hitchens and
they're under Christopher is already
above him was a little picture of Salman
Rushdie also an advocate of the war
against Saddam Hussein well for all the
right reasons I mean sometimes there was
a terrible dictator he had done horrible
things to his people he's threatening
the world it's a well I could say the
same things about Sharon for God's sake
or bush or both sure and I mean a lot of
people but does that mean that I want to
go to war that's what surprises me I
mean that there's a turn there for which
I don't find really your evidence in his
work at all right and for that kind of
for that kind of yeah and the amazing
thing is that we don't even know how to
theorize about the fact that these
people nevertheless get reelected and so
the the the formal elements of democracy
so don't seem to be have much to do with
the demos which what they're supposed to
be for and I don't think liberal
democratic political theory has an
account reduce that this can happen
repeatedly as it does in this country
and
okay I I think we're pledged to to raise
to allow the audience to to ask you
questions I know that you've been very
keen on actually talking about as other
novels the world of rock and roll and
know that what about the theory with
what about love and money and six in New
York I know you want to talk about that
in all right so we the discussion two
questions from the floor
I will and I will urge you not to get up
and make a speech but to to put a
pointed and brief question all right
Christians yes
no I can't
I'm afraid I don't know enough about
what his views on Kashmir are and you
I'll say just a word I I mean the
question should really be directed to
Edward but but I just my own view on
this is that the US has put a fair
amount of pressure on Pakistan to to
curtail its support of militant Islamic
groups in Kashmir with some success but
it has put absolutely no pressure on
India to come to the negotiating table
and come to a political solution on this
this is just an utterly inexplicable and
unjustified asymmetrical approach and
that is because they are in the present
climate India is an ally and India as a
country in which over 2000 Muslims were
killed in the matter of 10 days in the
US government didn't say a word about it
so it doesn't look very optimistic
sitting in this country yes
well does not I mean that's basically it
I mean he was part of a group that was
put together to help Netanyahu gain the
Prime Minister's position during the
election campaign of 1996 during the
period when the Oslo process had been
supported of course by the Clinton
administration had been from one point
of view going forward you know for the
past day in plain view is a rather more
complicated situation because there were
very few concrete changes on the ground
and in fact immiseration of the
Palestinian population under Oslo had
really quite seriously taken hold there
were this 96 was the year of the
closures the beginning of the closures
by the Labour government of Paris at the
time and the amount of land conceded to
the Palestinians in the peace process
had had gone up to about maybe 12% of
the West Bank and about 60% of Gaza
which was never desirable by the
Israelis at that time there was a strong
feeling in this country represented by
people like Norman Podhoretz I mean the
people on the extreme right and the
neoconservatives in this country that
there should be no concessions to the
past at all and that the whole peace
process and the whole emphasis of the
Clinton administration on trying to
settle the problem between the
Palestinians and the and Israel was a
was a mistake
that what Israel should do would be to
just as I said earlier to annex the West
Bank in Gaza to stop the discussions
between themselves and these and the
Palestinians and to take a hard line on
on the general situation in the Middle
East in effect aggravating aggravating
the tension between Israel and its Arab
name Arab and Muslim neighbors in which
you know for example Lebanon was thought
of as
not the place that should be retained
the Israeli occupation of south Lebanon
was then in its 18th year and they were
losing a lot of troops at the time but
the position of the Likud at the time
was that this should continue and so the
question was either to press forward
with negotiation or to take a very hard
position inside Israel and recommend
that Israel basically continue the
settlement policy that it should be
increased which it was and that that one
of the ways of relieving pressure on
Israel is was to turn a parallel is
absolutely right about this Reni that
you know that potentially the greatest
enemy for Israel in the Arab world was
not the Palestinians from a military
point of view but in Betty Rock because
Iraq was the was the only country in the
Middle East that was not overpopulated
that had immense resources both oil
probably greater oil reserves in Saudi
Arabia now subscribe as the second
largest proven oil reserves but it also
had water the waters of the Tigris and
the Euphrates which was unusual in the
Middle East whether you look at the
other oil-producing countries like Saudi
Arabia of course the Arab most of them
are just arid desert and desalinization
is a major you know major project it's
very costly and its results are not very
good because I mean the land is not it's
not fertile and so in this memorandum
that these people wrote for Netanyahu
which is available on the internet you
can get it they recommended all these
things including attacking Iraq which
you remember Israel had done already in
the early summer of 1981 when they
attacked the Aussie rock reactor nuclear
reactor which was supplied to the to the
to the to the Iraqis by France so you
can see the seeds of what's been
happening now already back then
and a position of this sort of hard
right group which included as I say
Wolfowitz it included Rumsfeld you know
many of the protagonist some of the
major figures in the current Bush
administration was you know pressing
Israel to take positions that are very
similar to the positions the United
States has now taken in the Middle East
it stopped a peace process it's has let
Jerome do what he wants in the last two
years since the Second Intifada again
thousands of Palestinians have been
injured you know 40 50 thousand its
major injuries in Palestinians many many
many have been killed you know four or
five times more Palestinians and
Israelis have been killed and of course
the settlements have continued and this
is US policy I mean when in June of last
year Bush got up and said that Sharon is
a man of peace every I mean the world I
mean I'm sure including Sheryl and these
the people whose policies now are you
know guiding US politics and and and
military moves in the in the Middle East
because of anything I think the idea is
to put Iraq out of commission not
because it's a threat to the United
States I mean obviously it's not but
it's a threat a potential threat to
Israel which according to this policy
must retain you know unquestioned
dominance military dominance over the
whole Middle East said he's right in
another thing that the new axis of power
in the Middle East would include Turkey
which is performed very well in my
opinion
by not going along but the idea was
Turkey Israel and India instead of
Pakistan Iraq the Gulf and so on and
this non arrow axis would would assure
you know continued supplies of oil and
mr. geostrategic dominance in this area
of the world and that's what the basis
of the wars in my opinion is about it's
not about the threat of Saddam Hussein
and he's a deeply unpopular horrible
dictator who they supported you know
their 15 years ago you know in the last
up to the last year or so before the
first second belvoir of 1991 so this is
transformational falls and if there's a
war the people who will itself I mean
the people who never had any
responsibilities people of Iraq we've
never had any responsibility for the
rise of said though I mean the US has a
responsibility from the kaisers number
those rounds are going to software and
Ralph Nader said the other day we know
that he has had these things because we
have the receipts in the first big
report supplied by the Iraqis to Blix
in the latter part of last year of 2002
there was an appendix which was not
published in this country was published
in Europe which listed the companies the
mostly American companies that supplied
the Iraqi regime the lastly regime with
the elements of nuke oh yes nuclear and
biological chemical warfare these were
simply deleted from the report which you
remember the State Department said was
just confection of Lies and Counting
people's characters rather than the
influence as literature and
entertainment values them we all talk
about but have the people in various
countries where the colonialism has
finished become somewhat more cognizant
and proud and aware of their rights in a
different manner than pre that's it I
don't know if I could answer that but
certainly I you know it's important to
remember that he was one of the great
champions of sort of post-colonial
people in Britain you know in his
various essays against you know people
like Enoch Powell and the racism and
discrimination against Indians in West
Africa in sit in Satanic Verses half of
it is not about Islam at all it's about
tachi right yeah exactly that's right
with me so he was he now I don't know
whether many people would recognize
themselves but certainly in in the
post-colonial world will recognize
themselves in novels like Midnight's
Children and the Moors last sigh because
obviously these are fictional characters
and are you know much more imaginative
and sort of playful creatures than they
are supposed to be portraits of actual
people living today but where I think
he's quite you know spot-on in his
depictions of say contemporary India is
that you know certain way colonialism
never ended I mean I think that's a very
important point that it isn't as people
say like Naik will say well they the
white man is left you know in fact the
white man doesn't there's a wonderful
scene in Midnight's Children which I
always remember quite it's a very
brilliantly done I can't possibly
reproduce its wit and
and humor here but there's a there's a
famous estate in Bombay owned by some
English people do remember they call the
MEK furs or methyl ethyl each candy yeah
and and and it's sold to the to the to
an Indian family by the Netherlands
right right but they stipulate that that
everything that they did yes the Indians
who bought it have to do also trance
that includes having martinis and high
tea at five o'clock and this is a
hilarious scene where he comes back my
father called the McCauley's bastards
well there's a kind of slavish imitation
of the British which continues in a way
but there's also I think another thing
that he does very brilliantly is that he
he he in in in his literature he depicts
characters who are extremely aware of
their own history I mean that they
understand that their history is a part
of their living reality is not something
in the past I mean I think that's the
great difference between him and an i
poll because Naipaul portrays the
post-colonial person in a way in novels
like gorillas for instance or in his
essays you know Eva Peron and and
Trinidad and so on that these are people
who are just sort of imitators of the
white man and they're to be treated with
a great deal of contempt
whereas which these characters are self
created I mean they are characters who
are created out of the self conscious
acceptance of their history and who look
forward to the new with with a rather
more complex awareness of the past and
of the present and of the and of the new
conflicts of society such as that he
explores in shame you know between India
and Pakistan between Indians and Hindus
and so on and so forth so I think on the
whole his his literature I mean the
characters in his literature as they
reflect the characters of the present
I think are much more accurate and much
more aging and much more optimistic you
know then they're not I say I think and
you know Conti they're the minor
characters in Midnight's Children the
sorts of characters you use of wanting
us to talk about but the character of
Mia of the love for instance who's who's
really you know a sort of low profile
equivalent of the kinds of things that
Maulana Azad stood for for instance you
know Muslims who believe in a composite
culture and and there's something very
touching about rich these sort of
understanding of that and sort of
smuggling them into the narrative in
those ways the magician's and and
they're sort of social sympathies and so
on which are so removed from you know
Indira Gandhi and characters like that
so but you're absolutely right to to
raise a question about characters like
that because it's really what makes the
novel such an affectionate book on
Bombay in India yeah the back there
can you tell can either of you tell us
if any of Rusty's work has been
translated into either Urdu or Hindi or
any of the Indian languages or Arabic oh
oh yes yes do any number of translations
of an Indian or do an Arabic to assume
no Satanic yes Shan was - and then when
he came and spoke here when you invited
him he was rather annoyed about pirated
translations and editions of it
available all over the South Asia and
Southeast Asia and some yeah there was a
question yeah
Tibet and then I I think which is sorry
listen is immediately related to the
question of translation but you must
forget that in now about two years ago
he went back to India after the whole
fatwa thing and rotors long piece for
The New Yorker but his return to India
with his son so he I mean he can go to
India and and although the filming of
Midnight's Children which was to have
been done on British television I
remember talking to me but he won a
legal case and got his house he got his
house exactly but they wouldn't allow
them to film there and they got
permission to do it in Sri Lanka and
that was also yeah taken away I mean it
was felt that you know he's the presence
of it you know for a big project like
that associated with Russia in countries
with with large Muslim populations was
still it was still yeah but Bruce is
redeeming all that over here in the
Apollo Theater yeah I'm taking us back
to only because of times and one of the
things that
is this notion that Naipaul there's a
recent article at believers in The New
Yorker about night polls
hold up bringing in the West Indies and
his relationship to Plus being Indian
Indian s in a society which was black
and white and blackness as a as the
other and one of these things playing
into his portrayal of West Indian lesson
colonialism whereas Russia I think never
went through those kinds of being as it
were and that would partially probably
account for his being far more
comfortable with the kind of
multiculturalism that he's advocating
what do you think of that I'm really
particularly thinking of this recent I
think you probably right but I think
it's also a matter of temperament
I got yeah I mean I think I think night
Paul's feeling about the world in
general I've only met him once at a
Conrad conference many years ago he was
he's a great you know fan of Conrad's
but and I'm of course wasn't seen him on
television and so on and so forth but he
he's a much more I think abrasive and
and as I put it he's a much more
judgmental writer I think then then he
is rush I mean in his style is much more
ascetic it's a much more pared down and
you know kind of English style in the in
the classical sense of the word the
diversities which is tumultuous and
turbulent and full of importations and
full of slang from the vernacular
monocular yarn sighing and lots of I
mean no it's a totally different
personality so you could say that maybe
my poles upbringing was rather more
challenging and more Rushdie's but that
doesn't explain it I think cuz I think I
think at heart just the last point I
think that heart nightfall is is much
much more conservative and you know his
feelings about modernity are deeply
Midland whereas my impression in general
of Rusty's writings are that that
modernity and I mean he's a he's a
postmodern novelist is really full of
you know of energy and newness and old
nurse sort of mixed up together he's not
he doesn't care so much about the proper
way of doing things in fact most of his
novels really parodies of that and so
that there's a whole difference between
the two of them and as I said I think
not Paul's feeling about colonialism is
much more forgiving and and much more
tolerant and and he's very very very
he's very severe with with the
emanations of in the world after I mean
you know I mean I mean in a novel like
Ben in the river
he's merciless about what is today the
present-day Congo really you know and
and very little is said about the
depredations of King Leopold's rule
which was horrendous I mean you know
millions of people were killed and that
forever distorts the country as Congo
has been a Connor I'd understood it much
better than I Paul did I think yeah it
doesn't explain it but it isn't also
entirely true because because Risty
talks about the terrible time he had
rugby and so on and similar sorts of
experience maybe not the same scale yeah
at times which I guess you can sort of
use a quasi position paper for the
current Bush administration I wonder if
you could talk about that in terms of or
maybe in relation to some of those
previous regs and thinking more
specifically of the mores left side when
he really just viciously Lampoon's Hindu
nationalism and that sort of rise that
has a very similar ideology I guess
currently of a very sort of anti Islam
ideology and how sort of those yeah I
mean I really can't talk about the times
shortly after September 11th I read it
but I can't remember I'm sorry but I but
I do remember one that came later in
which which I think the title and maybe
a year after that in which he writes an
essay in The Times which is called Islam
is the problem I think something like
that
and then his view is that you know which
i think is it's true I agree with it
that is that in large areas of the
Islamic world Islam has been captured by
you know the worst elements of dogmatism
and fanaticism and you know kind of an
absence of tolerance and so on and so
forth but what I I mean I don't disagree
with that you know but i but i but again
as I said earlier I don't think he pays
enough attention to the varieties of
Islam it's a much more monolithic view
of it then than I would volunteer that's
the one and number two it's quite
invidious because he doesn't talk about
the other monotheistic fundamentalists
and crazies that populate this world not
all of them are Muslim I mean there are
Christian fundamentalists who one of
whom is our president you know I'm sure
I'm really quite serious about this
these are people who are at least I mean
people who don't believe in evolution
for example I mean there's a lot made
about the schools in places like Saudi
Arabia and the my dresses as they call
them in Saudi Arabia and Pakistan's will
charge the plural he said I mean there
are places in this country where you
still can't eat I mean where it's a
the legal issue as to whether you can
teach Darwinism you could you can teach
evolution it's not surprising and
creationism has a very strong
constituency and the same I'm sorry just
one last point and the same is true of
Judaism I mean there's a lot of
fanaticism in Judaism today and the
people who go around killing
Palestinians on the West Bank I mean
I've had experiences of this where
people I've seen Israeli soldiers and
and settlers taking over Palestinian
lands and bulldozing the farm just
wiping out the work of faith of families
who live off the land and when I asked
the law offices to stop their land he's
told me the Israeli soldier in 1998 I
said whose land is that he says it's the
land of the people of Israel well I mean
you know he said what about that I mean
I think the phenomenon the monotheistic
well and I suppose they Hindu
nationalists to all of this kind of
fundamentalism and my opinion has to be
treated together that these are sick
Creed's that feed off each other but to
single out one say the problems are all
there is I think terrible I think one
really has to be and that's where I feel
you know Salman hasn't really been
forceful enough in in talking about this
that all of these religious I mean the
politics of religion of especially of
religious fanaticism are really
dependent on each other and you and
really have to be dealt with and opposed
together not you say well we want to
oppose this and not that I couldn't
resist saying that it's not surprising
that Bush doesn't believe in evolution
he's a living instance of its falsity
but but you know I just wanted to say
one thing you're absolutely right to
point out that the Moors last sigh is
is tremendously it's tremendously
critical of of Hindu fundamentalism so
there's a sense in which he is a little
even-handed but when it comes to that
but no I was just talking I was just
talking about his writing after 9/11 the
nonfiction architecture but you know
really it does seem to me that it's not
as if he is not seeing it mean he's
against religious fanaticism of any kind
but what he needs to focus on is the
kind of Muslim who is going to possibly
believe what he's saying
and that kind of Muslim is not going to
believe what he's saying if he or she is
constantly having to fight off wars
fight off talk about how they don't
believe in modernity and freedom and so
on and so forth and and he's playing
into that by supporting the small and
and so on
so it's not as if he's not even handed
he just hasn't he's confused about what
his own targets are and how to hit them
or approach them I think there's a just
one more point about this I think
there's a in my opinion there's a
greater disconnect or disparity between
his prose non-fictional prose and his
fiction now than there was during the
period of the you know of the decade of
the 80s which produced Midnight's silver
and shame and the Jaguar smile and now I
think he's caught up in in a world of
you know much much greater media
magnification and of course he's become
a great celebrity there's no question
he's probably the most famous writer in
the world and he went through a
harrowing experience during the years he
was in hiding and sought out to be
killed
you know during those four or five years
when he was underground and you know
persecuted and unable to travel really
you know that I remember when he came
here actually nineteen whatever it was
1998 or 1999 he told me that British
Airways would still not take him on a
plane I mean he he had to come on some
other airline I mean coming from London
that would you know one of the logical
things would be to take British Airways
but they wouldn't they still wouldn't
take him around but he can't have to
come on another and so that kind of
thing I think in the end you know
changes and perhaps confuses as they say
the individual yeah yes set forth by
Gabriel Garcia Marquez of magical
realism and national allegory how does
he what oh I'm sorry what was a lot o
you've spoken about who he influenced
with his writing how how would you say
that he reacted to his influences people
have shown parallels between Midnight's
Children and One Hundred Years of
Solitude
but for example this there's a great
deal of appreciation in him for writers
who are more conventional in years but
who treat similar themes of displacement
and discrimination Mateen
a collection of her short stories that I
recall quite well and in general he
seems to be very interested in novelists
who are like him you know
migratory who you know like the South
African writers in exile during that
period couldn't there uh you know an
East European writer also an exile
living in Paris I mean transplanted
expatriated and so on I mean those are
the people who mean a great deal to and
I have to say it I mean it's it's
because it's it was very flattering to
me he wrote very well about some of my
work and I mean it made a great
difference to me that he did about for
example my book on the after the last
guy which he and I did a YA dialogue
about in at the ICA in London which is
published also an imaginary homeland and
then in his latest book whose name I
can't remember collection also of essays
published by Random House there's a
there's a very terrific essay by him on
my book of memoirs after I'm out of
place so I think he has a very sharp eye
for people that he can identify with in
the modern world and they are in many
ways you know share a similar fate
perhaps you know which is out of being
not at home but abroad yeah
doctors say that someone who studied
Islam for many many years I was hoping
you could enlighten sort of Muslims that
are in this room as well as elsewhere
about these two questions that I have
first is what do you see is the sort of
the future of Islam in the West in the
post 9/11 environment when we see it's
not being polarized in married to
opposite ways especially here in the
West and the second question was how can
miss limbs create and proliferate a
progressive employers division of Islam
that respects basic human rights in the
culture of democracy in the Muslim world
what it's not going to be done by
America my view is first of all I'm not
an expert on Islam I mean that's a kind
of ridiculous over simplification and I
don't you know myself have any
particularly expert knowledge of of it
as such but but what has always
impressed me is that it seems to be much
more diverse and much more complex in
its manifestations then then similar I
mean so I I find it very difficult to
talk about the world of Islam which is
what often comes up in the in the in the
poem and I'm much happier with you know
political and historical experiences
that have occurred in to Muslims in
countries that have large Muslim
populations or majorities and I think I
think it's also true to say that you
know words that have become highly
demagogic like but leaving aside the
main one which is terrorism for which no
one has found an answer except that it's
always associated with Islam but I mean
most of the discussions that take place
today about the word terrorism I mean
there was a big debate in the United
Nations during the seventies trying to
define terrorism and they failed they
just were unable to do it nobody could
agree on it one of the reasons being is
that terrorism is always associated now
with non-state apparatuses you know
individual groups like the gladdened etc
and there I think there's a very
important component of state terrorism
which has simply never talked about that
states perform acts of terror
I mean the modern world I mean look at
look at Germany you could describe all
of that as state terrorism in in the in
the Nazi period any in any event what
what I wanted to say was this the
vocabulary of describing Muslims in
talking about moderates and modern and
modernizing you know this kind of
rubbish that somebody like Thomas
Friedman trades it you know they have to
reform and you know I I just find it
inconceivable that anybody could talk
about as vast the phenomenon is this
with as little knowledge first of all
before you can talk about the whole
world of Islam in these general waves
you have to know the languages and he's
now he's never demonstrated people like
him I mean I've never demonstrated they
have any knowledge of what takes place
I mean immediate knowledge of what takes
place in universities and so on and
schools all over the Islamic world and
second and most important who says that
the that the modernizing trend is set by
the West I mean cuz that would include
you know that would include having to
pass through the experience of genocide
you know which is which is not one of
the happier X experiments or results of
modernization I mean modernization is is
not an you know adequate yardstick you
know there was that wonderful exchange
between Muhammad Ali the boxer Ali as
they call him here and and somebody down
at the World Trade Center after 9/11
when he said the guy said to Haddad he
said how does it feel to the religion
that did this and he said how does it
feel to the religion to be a member of
the religion that brought us Hitler I
mean so you can play that game you know
and and come out with absolutely
ridiculous results but I what I'm trying
to say is in fact that if you take off
all of these labels and these phony
counters like democracy and
modernization and so on and so forth
you'll find that there is dynamism and
change taking place everywhere and that
I've written about this I think one
ought to be able to regard
cultures is going through a period of of
trying to define themselves I mean I
think that's really the major phenomenon
of the present period that we're passing
through whether in Islam or in the West
or elsewhere that that there's been such
seismic change not because of the end of
the Cold War although that's important
enough and not because of the nuclear
and the technological revolutions and
all of that stuff but because of
immigration but because of the vast
movements of populations that the nature
of a national identity has changed so
much that all these countries like
Germany like Pakistan which is a
relatively new country like Israel like
America are going through processes of
self definitions which which are which
are not over yet and which will are
beginning to redefine the terms of how
we think about the past how we think
about the present how we study history
what history do we study every major
culture every major society and minor
society on earth is going through that
period now and I think that's the way to
look at it not to use the invidious
terms that say well they're backward and
they are really pre-modern and they
haven't quite achieved this and we are
the more we are going to in the manner
of Rumsfeld and the other so we're going
to bring democracy there you know you
don't you don't import these things from
the outside or if you do you cause a lot
of damage thanks Todd okay they rotate